This is Jocko podcast number
44 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good evening echo did he mean,
and the last podcast number
43 when a little bit long.
Sure.
We did not get to the Q and a and that's
one of the nice things about having a
podcast,
having a form that we actually own
and can do whatever we want with.
If it goes long, that's cool.
What does it let it go along?
We can go down that road
now.
Some people might say, oh, you went too
far down that road. Okay, that's fine.
Press stop. You can go proceed
somewhere else. Some people say,
I wish you would have gone
further down that road.
So we're just kind of
going off of instinct here.
What to me like,
okay,
we think we think we went far enough
down that road. We're good there,
but we did not get to Q and a.
And so
that's where we're going to do today.
Do some Q and a questions
from the interwebs.
Does always good. A lot of
people, tons of questions,
definitely appreciate all the questions
that are coming through. And I'm,
I apologize, I can't get to
all of them. I will say this,
I've talked to some, some troopers
out in the field and they're, they're,
they're like it. We know what you're
going to say. Like when a question comes,
which is awesome, that means
I'm working myself out of a job.
If you're out there and you already
know what the answer to the question is,
that's awesome. That means
cool. You figured out,
you know what you need to go educate
someone else, go help someone else go.
So it's cool that people are
starting to understand, I think the,
the holistic mindset that's going on here,
and that's very positive to me.
Now that being said,
there's always questions that come
through. Sometimes even I'm go, okay,
well let me think about that one. And
some of them are really obvious. I got on,
you know, I got on a, on Twitter
the other day. Somebody asked me,
somebody said,
hey,
what have you learned about
people or about humans since you,
you know, kind of entered the world of
social media on a, on a large scale.
And I wrote back that I've figured out
that humans don't Google things before
they ask you the question on Twitter
because sometimes people just ask me,
you know,
the dis a question that you could
Google faster. The asked me about, uh,
you know,
just some quote the non one of my quotes,
but a Shakespeare quote or a book
or a military unit, you know,
man man,
Google that.
Don't ask me if you want to
ask me a specific question
that I might know some of.
That's cool. That's awesome.
I'm more than happy to answer.
Also I get asked 12 times a day,
what time do you go to sleep at night?
So I just read 11 and people
aren't laughing about that anyways,
but we do get some awesome questions
from the interwebs as well.
And the other thing that's cool about
answering questions from the interwebs is
it does make me think about that specific
situation that someone's in and a,
have I experienced it before, which
maybe I have, maybe I haven't,
I've at least probably seen it
before or some version of it.
But then once you answer
a question about it,
it quantifies and you bring it
solidifies it in your brain.
And now when I get asked that
question again and I'm like, boom,
I can answer it more,
I can answer with a little more authority
because I've seen it before that makes
it better.
So basically what I'm saying is when
I get forced to answer questions,
I am learning. Just like when
I'm reading a book I'm learning,
why don't we ask her a
question of learning? It's like
when you teach it, move a,
when you teach a move into Jitsu,
you get better at that move,
no doubt about it and that that's
why it is beneficial for me.
And I appreciate all these questions that
everybody asks me because they make me
smarter. Yeah, so all
right, rock and roll.
All question number one,
this one from those free,
you and Sam Harris. Sam
Harris. That's right.
Sam is sitting here by the way,
but the question is I would
like to start BJJ training,
but worry about injury. What are
your thoughts now? I actually,
we had these questions prepared for to
answer on the tail end of 43 and I will
say this, people want to know what's
in my mindset about things. You know,
what am I thinking? Here's one thing, and
you might notice this pattern. If you,
if you pay attention, close
attention, the podcast,
you might notice there's a pattern that
usually after these crazy dark books,
right?
I usually roll that first question in
the question and answer period is about
Jujitsu leg. Let's just,
let's just relax a little bit.
Somebody posted us, somebody k Bjj
cave man came and rolled with me. Yeah.
And someone was telling me, someone
that I know was telling me like, yeah,
my friend saw the picture, the video
of you rolling and they would like,
he looks like the happiest I've ever
seen him. And I was like, well yeah,
I was on the map.
So that's the general idea between let's
just go from the intensity generally of
a combat situation from a book into,
all right,
now we can take a wrap off and
we can talk about Jujitsu. Know.
I like that. Yeah, that makes sense.
So BJJ training and you're worried about
injuries. That makes sense. Actually.
I've got some,
I've got to ask this question a few times.
People that rely on their hands to
work, uh, one guy's professional,
actually two guys were professional
guitarists and they're sketched out about
doing Jujitsu.
Uh,
anybody that has a job that relies
on a lot of physicality, you,
you are at risk because you're, you
know, you're doing a sport. No injuries,
absolutely happened in Jujitsu.
It,
it is a contact sport and you can
get injured while you're doing it.
He can get injured in any sport
that you do. Any sports that you do.
The w the worst. My, I hurt my knee.
I had 80% tearing my MCL did it
surfing. Yeah. You know, Ben,
he'll hooked by dean lister of thousands,
but thousands and thousands of
times never had a knee injury.
I'm out surfing and hurt my knee
so you can get hurt doing anything.
But
so, so you have to be careful. Right?
And I think one of the best that one of
the most critical ways to be careful and
Jujitsu's by make sure that you're
picking the right training partners.
Cause there's some knucklehead training
partners at every gym and are there a
year old male
who has a lot of testosterone
and has a very sensitive ego.
And so he's looking just
to crush everyone. So you
gotta Watch out for that guy.
And I had, actually, I shouldn't,
I shouldn't actually paint that so broad
brush because there's plenty of people
that are, that are older people with a big
ego and younger people. There's people,
there's this basically you've got to
watch out for these knuckleheads that are
going to go crazy. Some people don't
know better too, you know, they're just,
they just happen to be being in strong
and they're not really knuckles or if
they're just like, yeah,
they're getting it. You know,
they told me to grab the arm and pull.
I'm trying to pass that guard.
I don't know that much technique. I'm just
going to go hard. Yeah, no, you're right.
They're, they're, they're not
intentionally being aggressive.
But Jujitsu is an aggressive sport
and if you happen to be 260 pounds,
that can be problematic.
So you want to,
and I know it sounds
weird if it goes well,
how do we roll some purple belt that's
just going to run through me. No,
actually you do Google belt.
The chance of you getting hurt by a
purple belt are infinitely less than you
getting hurt by a white belt. Absolutely
true. And the higher you go up,
the more accurate that is.
Unless of course you're a,
you're a, you're a problem,
right?
Or you're a bully and there needs to
be a regulatory situation happening in
which case of black belt is
not going to, you know, he,
he won't into youth though.
That's the thing. It's like true.
I think when you enter fighting sports,
punishment isn't being beat up. You get
beat up. That's part of the game. True.
It's more, it's more of like
an embarrassment thing or like,
yeah, like they're going
to wear you out, you know,
or make you look like
you soccer. It's, it's,
it's more of like a lesson thing in
that way. Not like getting beat up.
I agree with you. Now another piece
of this and I, this is just a reality.
Okay.
Doing standup,
you have a higher chance of getting
hurt, like doing take downs, heartache.
Takedowns yeah. Either judo type style
takedowns or resting sal take downs.
You have a higher chance of getting
a knee injury or an ankle injury.
There's no doubt about it.
Yeah. So you be careful.
Just think about what you're doing there.
Um,
okay.
W with, with standups, do you know
if you're a person that's, you know,
do you got to get alerts of
basic takedowns? Absolutely.
But do you need to step in there
night after night and get your full on
wrestling practice together as if you're
a 43 year old person that, you know,
you're a 43 year old cop that's working
the beat. You, you know, you need to know,
take downs, don't get me wrong. You
need to train them. You need to study.
You need to make sure
you know how to do them.
Do you need to out wrestle somebody,
you know, in a wrestling situation?
Probably not. You know, you're,
you're not going to need you that.
So just use caution with takedowns.
Um,
make sure you know how to do them,
but as you get to where you want to
not get injured is your point of your
primary.
Okay.
Thoughts training. Then just
be careful to stand up. Um,
obviously do a good warm up and this
is something I'm just the worst. Uh,
okay.
Perpetrator of not warming up.
Well, I like to warm up by rolling.
So it actually,
now I do usually do one round where I'm
just kind of chilling and just kind of
rolling flow. But I used to not even do
that. He's just like clap hands and go.
So don't do that. Obviously.
Keep your ego in check.
And I'll tell you another thing,
and I was talking about this
with Greg train the other day,
cause Greg dream popped his ribs.
Yeah. And he was just saying to me,
he's ribs recovered now, but he was
saying to me, you know, he's like,
I think you don't get injured because
you work out all the time. And I'm like,
I agree with you 100%.
Yeah.
So I believe that you should
work out on a regular basis.
And somebody just asked me, do you
train and lift on the same days? I said,
yeah, absolutely. I trained and lift.
I train and left every day. Yeah.
So get your workout program going on.
You know, make sure you maintain that.
Some people when they
start doing Jujitsu there,
they're going so crazy that they use
all this muscle and so they go, I can't,
I'm not going to work out because I'm
just getting a workout. No wrong answer.
Keep working out. And matter of fact, you
should. And I was encouraged working out,
lifting, doing your Matt Kahn, doing
whatever before you do Jujitsu. Mm.
That's what I do.
I want to be tired when I show up to
g two and fight in a worst scenario,
you know,
make it harder for myself.
I don't want to show up and be all fresh
and like that's going to happen every
day. No, I like to be tired, worn out,
stressed system and then show up and
still get after it on the mats. Yeah.
That part's pretty advanced though to
do it like that. I got to say, I mean,
being new as the question, I've
done that the whole time. Yeah.
And I've done that too before
and good. Yeah. You Do,
you work out after you lift weights after
you train Jujitsu? I've done both. Okay.
What do you do normally?
I do one and like I don't
do two days normally. Oh,
see when you roll into the mat,
you're like all fresh in a matter of
speaking at fresher than I would be if I
did a workout before. Yes. Let's
put it that way. That's cool. No,
but as of right now, that
is how it is. Yes, for sure.
But before and even when I was training
for competition and stuff. Oh yeah.
And even, yeah, like maybe like two
years at three years ago maybe. Um, yeah,
I'd work out.
I do the workout first and then go roll
out like in the, I think that's the plan
as much as you can work on
your flexibility and this
is something that I, again,
this is a big fail area in my book.
I'm not flexible as I should be.
And you, if you are more flexible with
your injury levels are going to go down.
Yeah. So, you know, stretch and it's
really easy stuff that, you know,
everyone says to do. You know, when
you're sitting there on the mat,
even when you're sitting in the mat
and the teacher's teaching Chino,
try and go to Lotus position. Try and
you'll just do stretches where doing that,
if you're sitting around,
just stretch while you're sitting around
while you're working on your computer,
sit in a way that you're getting
some kind of stretch. So,
so stretch and be flexible as much
as you can. Now another thing,
I kind of talked about
guitarists and anybody, you know,
a surge in anybody that's working with
their hands and wants to protect her
fingers,
I would recommend maybe emphasizing more
Nogi where you're not grabbing onto an
Aggie all the time. Yeah. Yeah.
And it gave me fingers get caught up in
there and need twists or something to if
in Yanco silk. Yeah. Every time.
Pretty much. It's fairly common.
Um, I actually, my worst finger injury
was actually Nogi. So that's an,
I only did it a couple months ago, which
is just, and it was just a bizarre,
you know, it's a bizarre incident.
He was one of those things.
So that's why it's really hard for me
just to straight up encourage somebody
that needs their fingers. Like,
no, no, don't worry. You're
not gonna get no, no, no,
you can't get her. Now I've had
one finger injury, you know,
significant finger injury in 20 plus
years so you can get a finger injury.
Cutting the carrots on the, you
know, in the kitchen is, so,
you know,
you gotta be careful,
but there's no guarantee that you're
not going to hurt. And I'll say it.
And the other thing is, I will say this,
you got some chance of getting injured,
right?
But there's also some massive physical
and mental benefits that we'll likely
outweigh the injuries.
The perceived injuries are the
possible injuries that you might get.
So you're just be healthier.
You're, you're, your fingers
are going to be stronger.
I mean, yeah, you might get
some injured fingers. Uh,
but you are also going to have
fingers that are stronger.
Your grip is going to be stronger.
So that's beneficial.
Your mind has to be stronger, your
cardiovascular systems can be stronger.
So there's a lot of benefits to
Jujitsu that outweigh in my mind,
the possibility of having an injury.
Yeah.
I mean a of having a catastrophic
injury is pretty small,
especially if you train smart.
Really is agree. Absolutely agree.
Yes. And when you think about it,
even of the people that you know,
over 20 years, that's a lot
of people that, you know,
oof had any kind of major injury.
If you count, it tends to do count
as a major injury. But you know,
if you blow out your knee,
that means you're gonna be down,
you're going to be six months of surgery
or whatever surgery and six months of
Rehab and then another three months
before you can try it. That's, you know,
that's a year. And that could be, some
people consider that catastrophic injury.
I know I would be devastated,
but at the same time, you know,
I or I got neck surgery,
I was out for a bit.
Don't even remember it now flashing the
Pan, who cares, whatever deal with it.
I played more guitar during that
time. You know what I mean? Good Times
in uh,
in reference to this question,
and this is anything you do guys on
the basketball court all the time. Oh,
I'll go up for just recreational
basketball pickup game weekend, whatever.
Blow their knee, ankle, whatever. You know
I had, I mean I've been in the game what,
12 years? I had one cause I was
getting nuts in a tournament.
Bicep tear, major injury, you know,
out for, you know, a year or whatever.
But other than that,
never been injured because of a
submission out of training too. Yeah.
In full speed training competence,
like everything in its
first submission holds go,
never been injured in a submission.
You know how like,
yeah, passionate time or
should, we should definitely,
if you're a smart judges declare you'll
never get injured from somebody trying
to submission.
Right.
Cause you tap, you tap in. Look,
it's not going to not hurt. You know,
if you tap too late,
usually it's just you get hurt.
Maybe your shoulders kind of whatever
for a week or we can still train.
It's not an injury. Put it that
way. You know? And even if, yeah,
even if you're your big smile,
I think that's pretty common.
It's really rare that I see,
oh I'm,
my ACL is out because of a heel hook
maybe in competition because you're trying
to, when you weren't trying to tap those
few. Okay. But yeah, generally speaking,
it's surprising almost
that it's that safe is,
well you can see that when you consider
what the objective of the sport is to
break and destroy people's limbs in the
fact that it rarely happens, you know,
it just really happens. So yes,
be careful. There's no guarantees.
But Trey,
back to the training partners
part, you know, when you,
the first one where you were saying,
be careful who you trained with
and stuff like that. So sometimes,
especially like, let's say
if you're older or, um,
even if you're a girl and
you go in and you know,
you're the only girl and you
know, some people will, they like,
let's say the guy doesn't know
any better and he's going hard.
You can tell when he starts to go hard,
sometimes it can be awkward to kind of
say, hey, you know, like respectfully,
I'm not going to roll with you.
And because of, you know, it's,
it's kind of like asking someone to dance
in them saying no, you know, like, oh,
it's like rejection.
So it's awkward.
So sometimes people will just tough it
out and be like, just try to endure.
I think if you can find,
you know,
if you can go through that and really
look out for yourself where, you know,
the guy's going nuts,
it's obviously,
usually he's not trying to go nuts
and hurt him. That's pretty rare.
But they don't know any better. They
were white belt or you know, whatever.
And they're just bigger
and stronger, whatever, and
they're going nuts. You got us.
You got to find the good, tactful
way to be like, Hey, I respect you,
but I'm concerned about like just my
injuries or whatever. You know what?
Hey, sorry. I only role with
people under one 30, cause I
have a, you know, uh, yeah,
injured, ribbed, Yay. And there you
go. Just just, is that a white lie?
Maybe it is,
but I don't think it's a malicious white
lies are fine when you're bring Sam
Harris. I apologize for telling people
that you tell a little white lie to save
themselves massive injuries,
catastrophic injuries. But again,
it's like telling someone no one,
they asked you to death.
So you can tell white lies.
The fact is meant for my own reasons.
I don't want to dance, you know? Yeah.
But it might be okay to say, oh, sorry.
Um, I'm here with Billy over there
and so I can't dance with you.
And that's actually gonna make you feel
better than just, hey, you know what?
Actually I don't like you.
Yeah, you kind of disgust me.
So I'm not dancing with you.
Walk away isn't necessarily
to do that. Probably not.
Maybe the little white lies. Okay.
Helps you again, Sam Harris, apologize.
We're encouraging line.
It's like things like,
I'm not going to say you're a Spazz,
you're a liability.
You might hurt me because of
what you don't know how to do.
I'm not going to roll with you.
That's different.
You know you mean you offended the guy?
Most likely so actually we were actually
talking about that while you are on the
Jujitsu.
Matt's doing physical Jujitsu.
Sometimes you got to throw in a little
mental Jujitsu in the situation and just
manipulate a little bit the mentality
of your training partners and that is in
the spirit of safety indeed because I
don't think chocolate would ever say that
to anybody. You'd be like, Oh, you're a
spazz. Bring it on if I'm not mistake,
you've got to deal with them people.
Next question.
When dealing with new groups of folks
before you go there, by the way,
sometimes you should train with someone
that's really a spazz and harder and
bigger than you.
You should do that sometimes.
Now you should use caution when you do it.
Maybe you can get that.
I would rather if my,
like my son,
if I'm going to have him train
with someone that's big and strong.
I'm sharing with you,
I'm having trained with Dean because I
know that you guys won't give him enough
strength to,
you know,
but you're not going to hurt him
because he's only 140 pounds. Yes,
but I don't want to give
the impression here,
like sometimes you got to roll with that.
Sometimes you got to roll with
somebody that's big, strong,
and doesn't know what they're doing just
so you're now you and I know what to do
there, but if you're a a
blue belt or a or a, yeah,
if you're a blue belt
and a big wrestler show,
then you weigh 165 pounds and a wrestler
shows up that weighs two 40 and it's
his third day and you're a
young guy. You know, it's,
it's a good idea to roll with that person
because they're going to do things you
weren't expecting.
They're really strong,
going to be trying really hard and
you want to be, you want to be,
you want to train for yourself for the
unexpected. So basically don't just weed,
I'm not saying we, and when I say, you
know, watch your training partners,
I'm not saying for a normal person that's
training crawl into a a safety bubble
while you're on the mats. Know especially
people that are, you know, young and fit.
You should be training with every person.
You can't every different body style.
Try Him out.
Big wrestles small people,
lanky people turn with them all
because that gets you used to all those
different buys also improves your game.
Yeah.
I'm saying if you are very concerned
about injuries because you have a job that
requires you to, you know, use your hands
or walk or whatever, then you go, okay,
you know what? I need to take the
long, the long vision here, the law,
fight the long war and really be
selective on my training partners.
Absolutely correct. Yes. Just like, whoa.
I mean just like other question is I'm,
I want to start Jujitsu
and I'm worried about him.
Exactly that guy. Use Your,
use your brain. Exactly.
But just like how you said,
when you get to about blue belt,
you got to start introducing
more challenges in different
ways and absolutely
correct men. Because if, if you
don't, you don't, and you can,
let's say you're not used to,
let's say you use the same trading
partners and you trained with, you know,
blue belts for a belt.
There is specific and very effective
Jujitsu moves for other Jujitsu moves,
right?
So it's like don't turn your back.
All these rules that are pretty
fundamental, that rarely should be broken,
and we all know him. So you roll
with a guy who's hits third days,
the athletic wrestler, he doesn't
know those rules, but now,
so he puts you outside of the
whole formatted you did to do.
And if you don't know it, it's
like Dang. It's almost like,
did you just not really working that
good? You know, if you're not used to it,
but if you are, you still
at, you'd be like, okay.
And that was such a good technique
to use with people, right?
When you're dealing with people,
people like people's personalities.
People have a personality that they,
that's how they deal with
things and they get people,
they funnel people into their world.
So if you have to break that,
just step outside their world, like don't
get drawn into people's worlds, right?
Don't get drawn into people's strengths.
I mean, we talked about it all the time,
but don't get drawn into their strength.
Don't get drawn into their way
of fighting because it's not,
you're not going to be able to win that
battle because you do it all day long.
Right? So just come at them
from a different angle,
usually disarmed or some cow instead
of being confrontational. We,
and this is just normal stuff,
but instead of being confrontational or
somebody take a little flank and maybe,
you know, massage their ego a little bit,
but that's it. It's exact same thing. If,
if people have a way of doing things
and you can get outside their pattern,
you have a better chance
of getting a victory. Yeah.
Yeah. That's crazy. How that,
all right.
When dealing with new groups of folks,
when do you do decentralized command
right away or gradually as in slowly give
them trust or slowly
take it away as needed?
Again,
this is a good solid question.
This is something that people ask on a
fairly regular basis and it's a pretty
straightforward answer. Um, okay.
You can't obviously just right away just
just give people full autonomy because
you have to build it up
somewhat incrementally.
Give them the opportunity to be on their
own now and what what you're really
building,
what you're really building
with decentralized command
is you're building trust
and and that that's what you're
trying to do. And as I've said before,
the best way to build
trust is to give trust.
But before you give trust,
you've got to set expectations.
You've got to set standards.
You have set guidelines because this
person that you're just a minute,
a new person, they might be, they might
be a crazy, they might be incompetent,
they might have a totally different
vision of what's okay then you might,
they might be unethical.
There's all kinds of things that they
might be that you cannot allow for,
so what you have to do
is set those standards,
set those guidelines and put those,
put those guardrails in place so that you
make sure that this person is ethical.
Make sure that they do our professional,
make sure that they do
have the same standards.
Make sure that they understand the
expectations. You set farm and that's,
that's when you can start to handout
more slack and more ownership because we
don't wanna micromanage.
When I was talking about parameters,
I'm not talking about telling people
exactly how to do it, but let,
let's say you and I started working
together and you are my subordinate.
If we fast forward two years
from now, I'd be like, Hey, echo,
this is what we're trying to get done.
Make it happen.
I'll check back with me
when it's done right.
That's how much leeway I'm giving you.
I don't even care,
but when we first started working
together, I'm like, Hey, echo,
here's what we want to get done.
Can you come up with a plan
and then and then let me know.
Let me take a look at what
you're going to do. Boom.
Now I'm still letting you fully own the
plan, but I'm going to do a little check.
I'm going to make sure that it's the right
gym and make sure it's a good plan to
make sure it's a smart plan.
I'm gonna make sure it handles,
are our resources correctly.
So all those things I'm just going to,
and then the more we work together,
the more we build the trust.
The more you understand the expectations,
the less guidance I'm going to give you,
the less oversight I'm going to give you,
cause I'm getting built up because you've
built up trust with me and I've built
up trust with you.
So that's important.
I also want you to be able
to make your own decisions
because I don't want to be making
decisions all the time, you know?
So even when you,
even in the first scenario when I've
been working with you for a long time,
you know, I say, Hey, echo goofy this out
you go, you go handle it, you get it done.
When we first started working together,
you might come to me and say, Hey Jocko,
I hit this wall.
What do you want me to do here?
What do you think I'm going to say? Figure
it out. I'm going to say, figure it out.
I'm going to say, hey man, I, I don't
know. What's your, what's your best guess?
Or how would you do it? Or, you know,
we knew each other a little bit better.
I'd say, hey man, don't come asking me
those questions. Go figure that out.
I don't care how you do it.
Just get around that wall.
Boom, and we're done. And
now the other one other key part of this
is oftentimes if you take over a new
team,
you may want to,
you may want to start off by setting
the example by running the perfect
operation,
by going from end to end with some project
that you set this standard on how you
want things to be. So every looks,
and he goes, okay, that's how, okay,
I see how he did that. Whoa,
he wants that done. He, oh,
he holds the line on that. So
that way everybody knows what the standard
is. So there's in, and I would always,
you know, I mean I would always, when I
start off, when I took over a platoon,
take over a squad like, okay,
we're doing this operation. Cool.
Here's how I would run it very distinctly,
very clearly be the guy.
And then as time goes
on and trust develops,
I'm going to become less and less
the guy and more and more the
the decentralized leader that's stepping
back and letting the frontline troopers
lead. That's what I'm going
to try and make happen. Um,
as always, when you do start with a
new group, it's real easy. Be Humble.
Listen, take advice, ask,
ask questions, ask questions,
ask good questions about things that you,
if there's something you don't
understand, ask the question. No big deal.
Make the slow incremental changes
like Hackworth talks about in steal my
soldiers started. He just gets
good and change two things a day,
not going to change the whole
world over night, can't do it.
So he's going to change two things a day.
That being said,
he also did some major to remember
if you remember this Hackworth,
he gets in there and the guys have radios
and they got guitars and they got all
this stuff and he goes, yeah, put a lot
of stuff in the middle of the compound.
It's Outta here tomorrow.
Right. That was a major change.
So he went and kind of shook them up
a little bit, but then he goes, okay,
now I've got to go the long war.
I'm to change to little things
a day and that's what he did.
So sometimes it's a combination of those
two. Sometimes you got to have to give,
send a little shock value
like, Hey, new sheriff in town.
That's what they used to
say in the seal teams.
So he's commanding officer
would come over if he would do,
a lot of times they do something to
assert their presence
like, Hey, I'm here now.
No more parking in the back
lot and you know what I mean?
Or Hey News,
new seal.
I just took over no more wearing
this uniform to this place.
Okay, so everyone go, okay,
new sheriff in town. Let,
let's let him get this out of his system.
Do they,
do they typically react in that
way where they're like, look,
I see what you're doing there.
Cool.
Pretty much in the seal teams it would
be like, oh, okay. Yeah. And Hey,
new sheriff in town. He just came
up with a new rule for us to fall,
so we know he's here. Cool. Right.
It's not like some resentment.
Maybe the guys that are less mature,
I use word,
but maybe guys that weren't quite
as in the game would be like,
what do you do when this poor be
a hey bro, don't worry about it.
It's a new sheriff in town. He's, he's got
it. He's let us know where he, he's here.
Yeah, he's got it. We got it. So
we're all good. Yeah. That's cool.
Uh, but occasionally see occasionally
you get somebody that comes in,
you notice the things that I just
said, we're, we're fairly irrelevant.
Like he don't wear this uniform there or
hey, don't park in this part, whatever.
Those are fairly inconsequential
things and those things are, are okay.
Actually occasionally you'd see somebody
come in and try and do it, you know,
execute some kind of a, a fundamental
change and that's where you go,
wait a second man,
you've been here for a day and a half
and you want to execute a fundamental
change in what we're doing here.
There's a, we have a problem with that.
We as we as the troops have a problem
with that because you don't know,
how do you know? Yeah, I knew
I've been doing this for,
I was at seal team one for eight years.
You know, you're going to show up.
I've been here for five years.
You're going to tell me how
it's better to do this and I,
that might not be the right attitude
for a young guy like myself to have,
but that's the attitude that you're going
to generate if you come in and try and
make fundamental changes
without assessing.
So show some tactical patients
when you come in and say,
okay, let me check this out. And
again, just to refer back to the hack,
the Hackworth story,
Hackworth was going to take over a
battalion that was all jacked up.
They were called the hopeless.
Right.
And he wanted a tournament
into the hardcore. So he,
his shocking thing that he did was
meant to shock and it was also meant to
square them away and was
also the right thing to do.
And they also had a bad reputation.
If he went in and took
over really good battalion,
he wouldn't go in there with the same
shock and awe type treatment cause they
don't need it.
So you got to,
you got to think about what you're doing.
But I mean most cases,
unless you're taking over some
kind of a problem situation very,
you might have to use
a little shock and awe.
If you're taking over normal shit
situation, all the boss got promoted,
you're going to go into, go into his
parole. Hey no problem. Come in there,
be humble. Listen. Then as you see fit,
make some small incremental changes. Yeah,
like the shotgun off thing. We'll probably
work against you in a, in a, you know,
a normal situation. Oh yeah.
It'll definitely work against you.
It'll definitely work against you now.
You now,
cause now you're thinking about it, now
you're imposing a plan on people. Yeah.
People don't like to have plans
imposed upon them. They don't like it.
They don't like it.
Even the,
even the big controlled military where
everyone's in our chain of command. No,
no one in the military likes to have
big new ideas imposed upon them without
fault and without assessment and without
explanation and without telling people
why. No, you don't do that
and that what you want.
And what you want to do is by doing all
those things, by building that trust,
by setting the standards,
by setting the guidelines,
by putting the guard rails in
place, by listening, by respecting,
by being humble.
What you will do is you will
lead people to lead themselves.
And that's what you want.
Yeah.
Explaining why I feel like that's
maybe an underappreciated thing.
I'll tell you what, it's not under
appreciated my book. That's the absolute,
that is the current, that's
a critical piece. Yeah, even,
I mean, people watch it,
they'll want to know. You could go in
and let me really, when you think about,
you could go in and change
some fundamental thing.
If you explain why and then everyone's
like, oh yeah, that makes sense,
but just like, are you saying if
you, if you roll in and you're just,
you make a fundamental
change, everyone's like, Bro,
we were doing it that way for a
reason and you just came in changed.
But he explained why and I
understand it makes more sane.
You get feedback because maybe what
you said is the wrong decision.
You might be saying something
that's like, right, you know what?
You didn't think that through
really all that well. Yeah.
And you need to discuss this with the,
with the troops and figuring
out what their assessment
of, of your callers. Yeah.
Yeah. It's again, one of those
things where when we talk
about it like this, like,
yeah, Yep. That makes perfect
sense. But it's, I dunno,
it seems it was funny is on the podcast,
just as an example,
we talked fairly shortly about going
to the podcast once every two weeks.
Right?
I didn't really give a good explanation
of why and you know what feedback I got.
It was a, you gotta be kidding
me. Well No, when this thing
comes out on Wednesday,
Jocko, I don't know what your problem
is. The podcast comes out on Wednesday.
And I had, and I got that
feedback from numerous people,
not only on social media but
also in a face to face. You know,
people that texted me and called me and
said, Bro, you can't go to once a week.
And there was people that I would say,
first of all, if you're going to do that,
you need to set some kind of warning.
You need to let people know we need some
time. And so it was, it was, it was funny,
but the, the essential thing that
I did not do is say, hey guys,
here's what's going on.
Here's a why I would want to
do this in a different way.
And I didn't really explain that.
You know,
we just kinda cause it wasn't an
actual decision that was getting made.
It was a consideration.
The consideration has been revoked
by the way we're holding the line,
we're holding the line and
when we do have to do that,
which may or may not happen,
but I will explain why in great detail
so everyone understands where I'm coming
from because I don't want
to leave anybody hanging up.
I don't think it'll be like,
Hey Jocko,
I feel like you don't really
understand what's going on here.
You know on the front lines, the front
lines, we wait for that podcast as long.
Awesome.
Next question.
Jukka what are some workouts to progress
in becoming more relaxed in the water?
I need to lower my heart
rate. Okay. Again, this is a
a good question. That's actually a
little bit of a universal question.
That's why again,
I like to take questions at apply
universally to multiple things.
Becoming comfortable in the
water is very important.
Water makes you better. Water makes you
a better person. And I'll tell you, I've
said this before and the seal teams,
one of the things that makes
us good in the seal teams,
we have to deal with water and
water is a pain in the ass.
It ruins things at floods,
things it stops,
it stops guns from working at stops
or radios from working at SOPs.
Humans from working,
you drown in it.
It's water is very tough to deal with.
It's a very harsh environment,
especially the ocean water. I, I used to
say that every time you go in the water,
it's a real world op.
Cause you can get killed,
you can be killed in the
ocean and you can get killed.
The ocean today if you
make the wrong moves.
So you definitely need to be comfortable
in the water. Now first things first,
water will kill you.
Water will kill you,
you will die. You don't, if you make
mistakes in the water, you will die.
So whoever is wrote this question and
whoever's going to heed my advice here,
note and be advised that water
will kill you. So when you swim,
you got to have a lifeguard. And
there's a couple examples, a guy, uh,
in mind that when I went through
seal training with who was a stud,
a complete stud,
he was the honor man of my
buds class and a great guy.
I mean, not just, I mean,
it's cool to be honor man,
that means you're a good athlete.
But he,
this guy was also beyond that was
just a great guy, extremely motivated.
[inaudible] name is Keith come euro.
And he was practicing breath holds
as he was in use as you know,
after we went through seal training and
he would get gone to a seal team and
served and he'd come back to be a seal
instructor and he was practicing breath
holds during a,
during an evolution for the students.
And while all that was going on,
you know,
they're doing stuff with the students
and he's down there practicing.
Raf holds on his own kind. He was
on his, well, he was in the group,
but on his own,
if that makes sense.
So there's a big evolution going on
and while this big evolution going on,
he's kind of doing his own thing.
Right, right, right. And he died.
He was doing breath holds.
He stayed down there.
He had a shallow water blackout and he,
he died and it was awful. I mean, what
a, what an incredible, incredible guy.
Um, we also had some seals, 2015,
um, that were in Virginia Beach, you know,
young studs getting after it,
training super hard and
okay,
they, they both died in, in, in a pool
in Virginia Beach. And again, you know,
these are frog men.
These guys are pushing
themselves and you know,
trying to make themselves better.
And they pushed that envelope
and that's what seals do.
And they pushed it and they went over
the line and unfortunately they were
training together at the same time.
So you gotta be,
you got,
don't train alone and don't train with
someone that's doing the same thing as
you. At the same, you can't yet Durer
the same thing together. You know,
it's a real, it's a real
simple rule to one up one down.
So if it's your turn to train,
I stay out and then you do your evolutions
and then when you're done, okay,
now it's my turn to train. You stay out
and you watch me. It's one up, one down.
That's the, that has to be the
standard. Again, people don't,
don't play around with the water.
You know,
I've had Shallow Water Blackouts and you
pee wee, they just come and that's it.
Your unconscious and, and if you, if
someone's not there to drag you out,
you're going to drown. You're
going to die. That's it. And
they, again, it's sort of,
you can tell that they're coming a
little bit and you get used to them,
but it's sort of like getting choked
out in Jujitsu. Yeah. You know,
you've been choked out before,
right? Yeah, many times. Yeah.
So you think you're gonna make
it? Yeah. And then you don't,
and you can push it too. That's the
thing, especially when you're training,
like when I'm trying to get stronger
at like chokes and you want to be,
if you have some fight in
you, you know you want to be
able to, to fight, you know,
so you push it a lot of times,
especially when you have experience,
push it a little bit and then
sometimes cause you just got to go,
you can feel the blackout coming but
once you go right past that point you're,
you can't tap anymore.
You go out, you know,
do you did to safe cause usually the guy
can fuel you go out and they let you go.
But I go in the water.
It's like you know what the event horizon
is and a black hole. Yeah that little,
there's a line.
If you go over that line you're done.
And that's exactly what happens
with your consciousness. You're you,
you can see that line. You're watching
it like oh I'm going to get, okay,
I'm going to make it. And then all of
sudden it's gone and you're over the line.
You're in the black hole and that's it.
So be very,
very careful when you're
doing this. Always have a swim
buddy, swim the lifeguard,
all that stuff.
Um,
now the question back to the question
beyond the safety portion is how do you
get more comfortable with water? You
spend time in the water, swim, surf,
spear fishing, snorkeling, scuba
diving, survival, floating breath holds,
treading water,
just d.
That's how you get comfortable in
the waters by being in the water.
Give yourself a little challenges.
Swim with swim with tee shirts and
your hands swim with your clothes on.
Swim Dee Dee,
jock while you're not just all those
things to get to be in the water and do
things and swim.
And that's how you get more comfortable
in the water and you'll rapidly increase
your ability to be in the water and
handle yourself in the water and you'll be
much more common than water.
And the reason I said this is a universal
question is because it's the same
thing with just about everything
else that you're going to do.
The same thing with swimming.
It's the same thing with doing.
You want to get going to pull ups,
do more bobs.
You want to get better at public speaking,
get up and start doing public speaking.
Same thing with shooting.
Like when people first start shooting
and they're all intimidated by firearms,
it's because they're not used to them.
So spend time shooting,
spend time around guns.
You'll get used to the muzzle flash.
It used to look concussion of the noise
and you will be more comfortable about
it. So that's what you
needed to do in the water.
You spend more time in the water
and and you'll get better at it.
You'll get more comfortable. But again, be
careful when you're doing it. The water,
the water will kill you.
What does de Jock me? Oh, uh,
it's a term that's as far as I know,
it comes from buds from seal training
where when you put your scuba gear on,
they call it jocking up.
So joc up and your guarantee
in the seal teams it becomes,
it's a term that means any type
of getting your clothes on,
you're getting your gear on, getting
your clothes on, getting dressed,
putting your jock strap on that.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know if that's where
it comes from. I think you can.
But they used to play,
you know they remember that like little
kids game hang man where you fill in the
letters. Well whenever the class
would make a mistake they would put,
they'd have jock up written on the board
and they'd put one letter in and then
when you spelled out all of jock up,
then they would make you do joc up drills,
which are not fun, but it's just
putting on stuff. Your gear. Yes.
But the jock up drills
involve ridiculously stupid
and hard calisthenic workouts
with your entire gear load out
or they would always, we used to,
you know what bear
crawling is. Yeah. Yeah.
So you had to bear crawl with twin 72
tanks on we bear crawl to the Chow Hall.
I mean it's a mile. He's, I think our,
I think our instructors got in trouble
for making us bear crawl with he. Yeah,
they were like the Geneva Convention
called it's a borough. No.
Yeah, we had to pick or
call in football. We had to,
there was an incident in camp
in football at Uah one time
where we were supposed to
be, you know, sleeping,
you know, lights out, whatever. And
the guy who will remain,
now his name is [inaudible]
[inaudible] is like when I was young,
I was like a freshman to wall
off the one guy and he, um, I,
I can say his name now cause
he admitted it afterwards.
But before they're allies, we would
add to keep his car totally classified.
Tupo get an afternoon to
under what do you do? W okay,
so people were messing about,
we're supposed to be in bed,
so security comes or whatever.
And like we, and one hide,
some say we, uh, wasn't me.
I wasn't doing it. And someone threw a
sandwich at the security guard, hit him.
And it was this big incident, the
sat, you know, in and of itself,
throwing sandwiches, a security guard.
This is more funny than anything,
but we're supposed to be in bed,
you know, we're a football team.
You can't do that, you know? So it
was like, Hey, who? Who was this?
If no one admits it,
everyone's going to get punished.
So of course everyone gets punished.
We're doing bear crawls across,
across the field nonstop.
So he was like,
I can relate to the bear crawl to
the Chow Hall. It wasn't like, okay,
bear crawl to here. And then it
was like, you're going all the way.
I don't even know how many times
we did it. One guy was like,
cry was crying. So this up,
whoever did it fits up crying.
Grown men cry. I don't like that guy.
Nonetheless. So yeah, bear called.
That's rough man. Bear crawls, no joke.
But I think jockeying up is because you
wear your jock start when you get in the
game, like a jockstrap jock. You know,
maybe one of the old Udt guys that
listens to the podcast will contact me and
let me know where Jack up came
from. Yeah, that's my money on that.
It's because of jock gearing this up.
Joc shop is like the manly, you know,
I'm not telling, not going down this
road. I'm already down the road.
Can't help that you dragging me along,
but I'm not going to agree with you.
Think you're wrong. All right.
There you go. You have that right?
Yeah.
Here you go.
Next question.
Yeah.
Let's go to the next question and
I talk about that one anymore.
You're losing me on it.
What's the dichotomy in having an ego?
When is it good and when does he get to
a point where you have to check your ego?
Okay.
Okay, so did I caught
him? He is pretty clear.
Um, ego drives you. Absolutely.
It makes you want to win.
It makes you want to perform well at,
makes you proud of your achievements,
makes you want to be number one.
And those are all good things.
And I fully,
fully have those myself.
I mean,
my ego will keep me up at night trying
to win at some ridiculously meaningless
thing in the world.
Especially when I was younger.
It was kind of stupid.
Um,
but the ego can also get you in
trouble or get you in trouble really,
really quickly. For
instance, I mean you can,
your ego can make you sabotage
your coworker that's all
on the same team as you
so that you can shine
them, right? That's ego.
You can vote down a plan,
a better plan because
that plan isn't yours.
That's your ego.
You can
chase some material items,
some things,
something that you don't really need.
Maybe in some cases it might
even be something that you
don't actually even want.
And it's just fueling your ego, which is,
which is a really bizarre thing to see.
It can make you step on your subordinates,
right?
It can make you undercut your
peers cause that ego flares up.
It can make you,
your ego can make you dig in,
dig in on stupid ideas that you've had.
Those are the kinds of things that ego
to, and all those things are negative. So
that's pretty clear to me where
ego starts going sideways.
And, and I would say, even though like my
ego is fueled me to, to, to want to win,
but I'd never was that out
of control where I was like,
screw and screwing people over because
I wanted to win. No, I wouldn't do that.
That wasn't part of my personality wasn't,
I'm not that.
Plus I was never really
naturally good at much.
So it wasn't like I was going to win.
The only way I could beat people and
things was outworking them. Yeah.
Other than that I, it
would be hard for me. Yeah.
Usually that kind of person who like you,
well then the two kinds of people,
one who is down to like screw someone
over or basically cheat cheating is what
you're doing. And it's
like, I want to be here.
They don't necessarily want to quote
unquote win because if you cheat,
it's not really winning.
You know,
the whole benefit of winning is like
overcoming certain things, you know?
But when you cheat, it's like, you know,
and you cheated, you know, whatever.
So it's less about,
it's more about you understanding really
what winning is and that's what you
like the winning, you know? Yes, yes.
So like people who undermine,
cheat and do this stuff,
it's like they don't want to win.
I was like a good case in point.
I remember when when I was going
to seal training, there was people,
there was guys that
would like brag about it.
They were going through the same seal
training class and me saying buds,
class and me.
But they would like brag about it and
like you could hear him talking to let's
say some random person. Yeah.
We're on the seal training.
I wasn't bragging about that holds
like, hey man, I'm a lucky I'm here.
And I realize that a lot of those people
quit because they were comfortable.
They just being able to say like seal
training. They were already good with it.
They were like, Oh yeah, I did what
I'm supposed to do. So me, I'll, I'll,
I didn't want to do that. I didn't want
to say anything until I made it through.
Yeah. And so, um, yeah, so,
so what I'm saying is similar
to what you're saying,
they were satisfied just by being
able to throw that out there,
that was enough for them.
So for someone that's willing
to cheat and when are there eat,
they're willing to step on someone.
It doesn't feel good to me,
it has never felt good to me.
Like if I got to step on someone,
I don't even want it. I don't
want that victory, don't want it.
So it's like they want to,
some people want to look like they won
and other people want to really win. Yeah,
of course. That's really the
difference. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So back to ego point,
when you start feeling like you're
doing some of those negative things,
that's when you've got
to put your ego in check.
That's what you got to support
your coworker instead of sabotage.
And that's when you got to pick the best
plan out there instead of picking your
own. That's when you
say, do you know what?
I'm happy with what I have in state of
chasing things that I don't even need.
You know what I'm talking about,
what people like if you were,
there's been something that you wanted
even though you actually didn't even
really want to put, you just want it just
cause you, cause it's pure ego. Pure Ego.
Yeah. Like when you're in the weight room,
well growing up like lifting weights,
some guys would do this where they'd be
lifting weights and you can see a lot of
times in these like,
like a 24 hour fitness situation
where you'd be lived guys,
we'll be lifting weights. And
then one guy was, he's like, Dang,
he's lifting kind of a lot.
You'll see someone all of a sudden
be doing that same exercise,
like trying to live more than that.
He doesn't know him not lifting with him.
He wasn't even doing that exercise.
So it wasn't even his workup.
But he'll try to do it, you know? But
you weren't even doing that exercise.
You weren't doing bench today and now
you're doing bench chasing something you
don't even want,
don't even want it.
They don't need it that day.
Uh,
that's another big one is like
when I talk about subordinates,
instead of cutting down your subordinates,
you start lifting them up,
you start making them shine,
you start giving them the credit,
making them shine even
brighter than yourself. That's,
that's the beautiful thing.
When you can put your ego in check
and you can make that happen.
Making your own boss look good,
having an open mind to new ideas.
Those are the things.
That's how you put your ego in.
Check those or the things that
those are the, those are the
hallmarks of having your ego in check.
Now sometimes people don't know when
they need to put their ego in check.
And I think there's one really easy
indicator to know when you need to just at
least like do an assessment of your ego.
And that is when you're coming to
conflict with another person cause cause a
huge percentage of conflicts that
you have with other people. Our Ego,
our their ego.
And so when you feel that conflict,
whether it's about positioning,
whether it's about an idea,
whether it's about a plan, whether it's
about, well, no matter what it's about,
but if I'm in conflict with you on
something, immediately I'm going to say,
okay, what does that going? Is
this your ego talking or are you,
is is this business or is this ego?
And if you do that, you will
find yourself, you know,
any form of frustration
or anger that you have.
Just check your ego and there's a good
chance that you're going to be able to
take that thing, get ahold of it and
aggressively put it in check. It's hard.
Your ego is a tough
bastard. Your Ego, man,
that thing wants the spotlight.
It wants to shine,
it wants the glory and
it's, it's driven. You know,
that's a lot of high achievers out there.
That's what's driving you.
And that's not a bad thing. So when
it comes time to harness that bad boy,
it can be a challenge, but it's very
rewarding when you make it happen.
It's,
it's rewarding in a long term.
It's not immediate gratification.
Yeah. Generally, you know you're given,
you're given your subordinates
to all the credit for some,
for some project that they did.
You know that you could actually know
that you did the bulk of the work.
Would you give it away? That's
not gratifying. Immediately
immediately is like,
yeah, that's right. Put
the accolades on my head.
That's immediate gratification that
you're looking for. No. You say, Hey boss,
you know what? Don't put the
accolades on my head. Look at my team.
Let's crown them cause they really did
a great job and I'm just here to help
them.
There's no gratification in that,
but when you get feed back a week
later, a month later, six months later,
people want to come
and work for your team.
Now your team gets picked
for another project.
That's the long term gratification that
you get when you keep your ego in check.
Yeah.
You
that ego in check.
People meal.
This year I took extreme ownership over
every detail and mistake on a of the
roofing company I was starting.
But instead of inspiring my employees,
they just got entitled because of the,
because of this,
the business almost ran into the ground.
In addition,
I got so worn down then my resolve
almost collapsed. In your estimation,
what did I do wrong?
So this is an example.
I don't see this all the time,
but I do see it sometimes and
what we have here is, you know,
clearly guy steps up and says, you
know what, I'm going to take ownership.
I'm taking extreme ownership,
which is what I'm always encouraging
people to do life. And I wrote the book,
we called the book extreme ownership
because that is the fundamental principle
that we see as the common trait that
makes people successful is when they're
taking ownership instead
of blaming other people.
So that's what this guy did
with the roofing company,
Ham and take ownership
of all the mistakes.
Now the problem there is with the,
the,
the concept of extreme ownership.
It means taking ownership of the mistakes,
taking ownership of the problems.
But it doesn't stop there.
That is simply where you start because
the real true ownership that you need to
take as you need to take extreme ownership
of the solutions of implementing the
solutions of creating and
implementing the solutions.
That's what you need to take ownership of.
So in a situation like this,
like for instance, Oh, I
took ownership of everything,
so my team became entitled
now, now first of all,
in in that statement, in its
own right, if I say, hey,
we failed because my team became
entitled, what did I just do? Blame them.
I blame them for becoming entitled.
Why did they become entitled?
I allowed them to,
what am I going to do solve that?
I either have to train
the am treating them.
Maybe there's a couple of cancers in there
that have that attitude.
I need to fire those people or replace
them or get them retrained or put some
ownership on them so that they realize,
oh, okay, oh, I'm going to get,
I'm going to lose my job if we're,
we're going to fail this mission or
the companies go out of business.
If I don't do this right, so you got
to, that's the mistake there. What do I,
so you've identified the problem, you
take taking ownership of it. Hey we, hey,
we got to make sure we get our
jobs done on time. Okay boss,
well you didn't order the gear and time
and you didn't do this and now we're
behind. So it's not our
fault. You, and by the way,
pay me if that's the attitude
your employees, have you
got a problem as leader.
So what is the problem? How
do you fix that problem? Um,
the,
yeah,
the thing is about ownership is taking
ownership of the problem doesn't fix the
problem, right? It
doesn't fix the problem.
You still have to come
up with the solution. So
that's what it is.
When we talk about extreme ownership,
we're definitely not just talking about
owning the problems, but like I said,
owning the solutions and owning the
implementation and actually carry to,
it's to,
it's furthest stretched
to its furthest outcome.
That's where you have to
take extreme ownership is of,
and this is the most important part.
And obviously I need to make this clear
enough because this should be something
that everyone fundamentally understands
when they talk about extreme ownership.
The most important part for you to own
as a leader is the outcome is the end
state.
If you are not meeting your end state,
that's what you have to take ownership of.
That's what you have to make happen,
so that's it. You know when your,
when your company's not
doing the right thing. Yeah.
You got to take ownership of the
mistakes that happened. You got,
you got employees that are
acting wrong. Yeah. Hey,
it's my fault that they're acting wrong.
You got deadlines at, you're missing gas.
It's my fault that we
missed the deadlines.
Now you got to go back and
ask yourself the question,
how do I make the deadlines?
How do I fix those employees?
You got to solve those problems
that are out there. Otherwise,
extreme ownership doesn't
do anything for you,
and we've talked about this before
as well and that is that it's taking
ownership of things is not a,
it's not a a shelter,
right? It's not, it doesn't
provide shelter. Yeah.
It doesn't it and some people think it
does. They go, hey, you know what? Hey,
we missed or we missed the we, we
failed on our mission. It's my fault.
Okay, so let's move on. No, no,
no, actually no, we don't move on.
You failed in your mission. How
are you going to fix it? Yeah.
Extreme ownership does not,
does not give you any mercy whatsoever.
That's what's hard about it, and
by the way, the thing that lifting,
that extreme ownership that makes it
hard is because the previous question,
it attacks your ego because when
you say, hey guys, this is my fault.
You're not just saying, hey guys,
this is my fault. Let's move on.
You're saying this is truly my fault.
We failed because of me and these
are the things we're going to do.
Fix it and I'm going to own it until
we get it done. Yeah. Dang. Yeah,
that it kind of makes sense.
Like it is one of those all or nothing
things you know were extremely, he can,
it's just funny how you put it.
You know, where you're like,
I did my extreme ownership.
The rest is up to you guys kind of thing.
He can't really do that.
And this question is, is,
is a really good question and I appreciate
it because you can see the guy that
asked it, he clearly is motivated,
wants to do well, but he, he,
I, but again, my fault for not
explaining this well enough,
he fought that just taking ownership
would solve the problem. No,
you have to take ownership and
solve the problem. Matter of fact,
that taking ownership part is the initial
part that lets the rest of it happen.
And, and that's why we emphasize
it so much because most people,
they just don't take on it. They're
not even close. This guy, he's close,
he's taken ownership. Now he's got
to realize, okay, I took ownership,
I realized that it's my fault. And again,
it's not just him saying, uh, well it's,
it's my company so it's my fault.
And so I hope this works out. No,
I don't hope anything. You fix it.
You make it happen. And I, again,
I appreciate this question because I
could see in his earnest asking of the
question like, he's like, man, what
did I do wrong? What did I do wrong?
Here's what you did wrong. You
know you, you made the first step,
which is the hardest step.
That's the positive here.
One of the most positive things about
this guy is he's made the hardest step,
which is, okay, this is my fault.
The follow on is what he missed.
Now how do I fix it?
What do I do to implement it? You got
lacks of days, nickel entitled employees.
That is your fault.
So how do you fix them?
Because if you're lackadaisical
and entitled around me,
that means I'm doing something wrong. I
mean, if you don't understand the mission,
you don't understand why
we're doing what we're doing.
You don't understand why it's important
to meet the deadline on this roof so we
can move on to another one so that we can
collect money to pay for our next one.
There's all kinds of reasons that you
could tell people why these things are
important.
And if you have people that you,
they know exactly why they're doing
what they're doing and they still aren't
getting in the game, you need to find
some more people to come and work for you.
Some different people,
some people would better attitudes
and bring them on board with the right
attitude. You have this, um,
even to add to why this is such a good
question is this is exactly what people
are scared of with the extreme
ownership. It's like, Dang,
if I take extreme
ownership over everything,
they're going to take advantage
or they're gonna, you know,
be entitled or whatever. I think,
I mean, even thinking about it,
that's what I'd be afraid of. I am afraid
of, you know, and, and I will tell you,
having done this my whole career,
when you take ownership of things,
people don't there.
There is a small chance,
there's a couple of knuckleheads like
these idiots at this guy has working for
him that are entitled.
Now,
I shouldn't say that because he may have
provided the environment to become like
he might've been the easy button
and every time they say, hey boss,
I can't fit a boss.
I can't come in late today.
Can you finish up that roof by yourself
and who? He's like, Hey, you know what?
I'm going to take ownership
of this, right? He goes, okay,
I'm gonna take ownership.
Don't worry about it. I got it. Now
he does that four days in a row.
He's worked 16 hour days. He started
to get broken mentally and physically.
You ever done roofing before? [inaudible]
roofing? Yeah. Yeah. That's hard work.
Especially in the summertime when the
blazing sun eat 1416 hour day I had to do,
I pulled a chimney off my
little chimney off my roof.
One time I thought I was Neil
just patched the roof. No,
I had to strip like a third of my roof
on my house and then I'm up there.
We got rainstorms coming. I'm
up there and okay, I got a roof,
this whole thing and the next one
is an 18 hours. Get some. Yeah.
So roofing is hard work.
And if,
if you don't take the,
if you don't,
if you don't get these
employees in the right mindset,
if they're not part of the
team, if they're not on
board, how you gonna fix that?
If you,
and what I was going to say is if you
become the easy button all the time,
then that allows them, it fosters
the attitude of, hey, you know what,
uh, this is on Jocko. He's the one that
he's still got to pay me. Like, no,
actually here,
let me tell you how it really works.
You know how I pay you
regardless of what you do. Well,
eventually I don't pay you
anything because you don't
work here and I don't have
a business anymore.
So if that's where you're at,
Donald wants you here and I
will do this myself and I'll,
I'll schedule my job's appropriately
so I can do it all myself.
If you want to get in the game and be
part of this team, which you should,
then this is what I need from you.
Here's the expectations. This is why,
because next year,
this year we did 14 roofs.
Next year I want to do double that and
that means I'm gonna get you a crew
that's going to work for you and you're
gonna bump your pay up a little bit.
I'm going to get you moving
along and get you promoted.
Maybe sometime you'll have two
or three teams working for you.
Do you want to do that or do you want
to continue being the guy that's hauling
shingles all day? Are you in the game
with me or not? Are you part of this Gig?
See,
so you got to get in their heads.
You got to get them out of that mindset
and into the right mindset so that you
can dominate. Yeah. I feel
like that extreme ownership
kind of provides that to,
you know where if like
how you've always said,
if you're like blaming them overtly,
blaming them, they're like, oh,
this is good and not on my team. They
have that feeling, but if they're like,
if he's taking the responsibility,
it's like, Oh Dang this kid.
It's kind of on my team. Yeah. I do want
to do all that classic exit. You're right.
Classic example. If I approach
you and I'm like, Echo Dude,
you're just entitled, you are entitled,
you don't have a good attitude.
What attitude do you have now? Yeah.
What? What attitude do you have now?
Now you're like, oh, what are you talking
about? I'm entitled, I'm entitled. Yeah,
you're damn right. I'm entitled
because look at what I've been doing.
I've been no. Whereas if I, if I take a
different approach with you and say, man,
look, I think you've got a
lot of potential. You know,
I think you got a lot of, no,
you got a lot of things going on at home
and I know you've got that girlfriend
and I know you're doing this and that,
but you know what?
I think you've got some potential here.
Let me tell you what it's going to lead.
You know,
I know you don't want to be carrying
shingles were asked your life and
on your knees smacking nails, right?
But maybe you could be running a
crew and this is how I want to grow.
Do you kind of want to get in the
game with me? Cause I think you might.
You see what I'm saying? That's all
it takes. You understand me? Yes.
Good question. Thanks. And
Good luck with that company.
Small business owners get getting after.
It's hard. Running a small business.
It's hard work. You are, the buck stops
with you whether you like it or not.
Because even if you, hey,
you know what you mean?
If you don't want to take
extreme ownership, if you're
a small business owner,
eventually you're going to get put on
you. It's on you, it is on you. So it's,
it's uh, it's great. I love,
I love the small business owners getting
after it out there. Next question.
Thoughts on how to deal with
toxic slash negative people?
Oh, those people. Yeah. So first of all,
it's important to recognize that those
people exist everywhere and everybody's
got to deal with me.
If you run into one of these people,
don't get all surprised as if they're
a lone ranger out there being negative.
No, there's negative
rangers all over the place.
So we gotta do you gotta
know how to deal with them?
And it's so, so when you're dealing
with someone like that, first of all,
confronting them, of course,
as you can probably predict,
is not usually the best option
because all you're doing is you're,
you're attacking their heavily defended
position, which, which is not good.
So one of the techniques that I use when
dealing with these kind of people is I
absorb,
I absorb their critiques,
I absorb their toxicity,
I absorb their negativity.
Now obviously this takes a
little bit of strength, right?
You can't be taking stuff personally.
You have to,
in order to learn how to absorb
thing, you gotta say, okay,
I'm just going doing this for the
team. Right? But it looks like,
for instance, when they say, oh,
this is horrible. I don't say, no,
it's not horrible. I don't just go right
back at them. I say, yeah, you know what?
We definitely got some room
for improvement, right?
So I kind of just deflect.
I kind of just absorb, absorb it,
right? It was sore, but a little bit.
Because what they want to do
is they're lashing out, right?
They're throwing the negativity.
They liked those explosions.
They like to see it hit something and
blow up. They, that's what they're doing.
That's how they roll.
So you're going to absorb,
you gonna catch it and pull it
in. Right? So when they're like,
we can never do this, I don't say
we can absolutely do this. No,
cause you didn't.
You're just going,
you're going to create the explosion that
they're looking for in San. I'm saying,
you know what? We might not be able
to do it. I'm going to give it a,
I'm going to give it a good solid try. I'm
going to try and make it happen, right?
So we're just deflected a little bit
and they're going to show you some other
negative thing. And you
know, if they say, oh,
this is stupid, I don't say no, this is
the most brilliant thing I've ever seen.
I don't do that. No. Go head to head.
I'm going to say, you know what,
there's definitely some room
for improvement the next
time around. You're right.
100% oh yeah.
You just got deflected
and those reactions,
they disarm these ultra
negative people and
it kind of takes their,
their fight from the,
and it also makes them look
like emotional extremists.
So with the group, right, when somebody
calls that out in the group, they,
they're common across all extreme and
you just absorb it and negate it a little
bit.
It negates their view or it,
I shouldn't say negate cause negate me
is like totally Latins and cross out when
you just absorb it and deflected a little
bit, the rest of the team goes on. Yeah.
You know, Oh echo, he's just super
emotional and he's a negative.
They see him for what he is,
which is helpful for you.
Right.
And then once I'm done absorbing their
attacks and taking some of those shots,
no big deal that I'm going to start
to override them somewhat with some,
with some positivity, which is
going to be directed at them. Right.
So they were all negative,
but I'm going to say, Hey,
what you did there really work well or
you know what? Hey you good job on that.
I didn't know that.
I didn't care.
I never could have figured
that out like you did. Right.
So I'm going to start getting in their
head a little bit and start filling their
head with some positive stuff. That's
right. That's what I'm going to do. Bad.
You figured that out better than anybody.
Nicely done.
And I'm bringing them
from the dark side over to the light.
That's what I'm doing.
I'm bringing them over. And actually
I used to have the funniest up, uh,
one of my favorite guys in the seal teams.
He was my,
he was my first deployment to Iraq.
He was the senior enlisted guy
in our task. And it's, and,
and actually we're just boroughs.
But when one of us would start getting a
little off the reservation on something,
like getting all addicted to some idea
or something, the other one we would,
we would be looking like
I'd be telling them, look,
we need to do this and this is bullshit.
We need to do.
And he looked at me like he'd be like,
come back,
come back to the life where over here
it's okay. We're all going to be okay.
So when I would start getting negative,
he would start pulling me
back to the light. Right.
And same thing with, with me,
with him, he would get, he
would get all, you know,
get all matter of fact he's
the guy, remember when we
talked about will simplify,
repeat, no. Simplify, amplify and
repeat. That's it. Yeah, that's it.
He would also have to bring me back from
the dark side and I have to do it to
him too if he started getting
a little too negative. Um,
good times. But the, the,
the last thing I want to do with someone
that's being super negative is I am
actually want to,
I want to give them some ownership.
I want to give them some ownership,
some ability to make changes,
some ability to have some kind of
a positive impact on the mission.
So I'm going to pick something that I
think they can step up and handle, right?
Something that is within their grasp and
realm and ability and I'm going to give
it to them and,
and then I'm going to give them,
I'm going to give them one to kind
of overload them with help and with
assistance and with guidance
to make sure that they win
and that's going to start spinning them
in a more positive direction. Yeah.
So that's my way to deal with the
big negative people out there.
Just absorb and slowly counter.
I liked it how you're maybe like,
like how you figured that out,
and I said this before, but a good
one is to be like to say, hey,
that's what I like about you. You're
real whatever, x, Y, z. You know,
even that feeling like,
because people said that to me.
That's what I like about you.
You're real whatever,
you know and it makes you want to
like continue to be that you know,
and you're like, Hey, he thinks
I'm, you know, a problem solver.
Someone who I'm going to be aware and
to continue to solve problems. You know,
you put the self fulfilling prophecy in
their own heads and positive things that
you want them to do. Exactly.
Yeah. That's a good times.
Jocko. Next question. The
next question, Johnson do it.
I'm an I n t j personality,
my drive slash ideas often
cause friction with superiors.
How can I use my strengths
without creating division?
Okay. I uh, so for this one
I, I kind of had to look up
this stuff to remember exactly what it
was and the like the I and j t r I n t j
stuff is
in introverted intuitive thinking,
judging. This is part of this um,
Meyers Briggs type indicator that
refers to one of 16 psychological types,
right?
So it's sort of a graph that you can
figure out these what type of of 16
different psychological
types that there are. And so,
so for this one in particular,
this I n j t which like
I said is introverted,
intuitive thinking and judging and I went
to the interwebs for this and it said
that as an I n Tj,
your primary mode of living is focused
internal air internally where you take
things in primarily via your intuition,
your secondary mode is external where
you deal with things rationally and
logically.
So
speaking of self prophecies,
this is kind of one of them and I,
you know, as far as I'm concerned,
your personality in anyone's personality
is not set in stone by by any stretch.
And of course can you have some
natural tendencies as a person,
of course you,
you do have some natural tendencies and
if your brain was on autopilot you would
steer towards those
personality traits even more.
But luckily our brain is not on autopilot
and you have your hands on the wheel
had you can control your mind
and you can in this case,
you know, step back and, and,
and get a grip on things that you know,
according to the question
that caused friction,
right?
If
as if as an I n g a t you are supposedly
too demanding and these are little
quotes that they had.
If you're too demanding or not open to
other people are not open to other ideas.
Here's what you do. Real
simple. Get less demanding,
right?
If you have a hard time listening to
other people listened to other people,
if you,
and this was another quote I got
from the I n j t personality Matrix,
if you are supposed to have a low
tolerance of emotion in others,
then get more
tolerance for emotions in others.
This isn't hard.
You identified what the issues are.
You've heard me say this all the time,
listened to other people,
treat them with respect.
These things are not doing
that, so do them. That's,
that's really simple.
There's no reason to you for you to
fulfill this prophecy of being a person
that's not open other's ideas.
A person that's not,
that has low tolerance for other people.
There's,
there's no reason for you
to be overly demanding.
You don't have to be this way just
because that's your personality type
allegedly. That doesn't mean you have to
be that way. He goes, it's kind of like,
um, you know, the, the,
the horoscope signs,
right? Sure. And I do people
even talk about those anymore?
I didn't know my dad well, what is
it? Horoscope or astrology? Astrology.
Is that the same thing? Yeah. Yeah.
Well you read your horoscope, but the,
the based on the magic
of astrology. Yeah. Uh,
yeah, people still do that.
So, so when I look, when I die,
it hasn't happened to me in a while, but
when I was younger, um, people would say,
you know, like, oh, what, what sign are
you? And I'd say, Ah, I'm, you know,
I'm a Scorpio. And they say, Oh,
I could tell you are a Scorpio.
Yeah.
I totally pegged you as a Scorpio.
I saw that. I go, actually,
I'm not a scroll down.
And I'd say, you know,
actually I'm a Libra. And they'd
go, oh, go, no, no, have, yeah,
for sure. You're a Libra
all the way. Definitely.
Cause you have this and you're that. And
I go, actually, I'm kidding. I'm, I'm,
I'm actually a Virgo.
And then they wouldn't trust me anymore
and I was a bastard and whatever.
But my point is,
according to some random Zodiac calendar,
it's,
you can place those like
okay
overlays on anybody and you can
kind of make them fit. And I,
that's what I'm saying is like,
I'm not saying that the, that the
ENTP or s j or element,
Opi or whatever,
I'm not saying that the Myers Briggs
thing is just wrong. I think it's,
I think it's good to have a framework.
I think it's fine to have a
framework and say, Oh yeah,
I recognize this trait in myself,
or yeah,
I recognize that trading myself or I
recognize that trait in someone else and
then you can deal with it. I think
that's good. But what I don't,
what I don't accept is saying
this is what I am and therefore,
um, I'm not going to change
no wrong answer. If we all
just accepted who we are,
you know, you're, you're not going
to make any progress, you know,
so you find some weaknesses and your
personality and you fix them. That's,
that's what I'm saying. Adapt yourself,
evolve. Get better, stop creating fiction,
friction, stop creating division,
be humble, listen, take input,
all those things.
And,
and I'll tell you one last
thing is if you really are, uh,
the,
the I n t j didn't,
that means that you're smart.
It means you're thinking,
it means you're pragmatic.
It means you're an analytical person and
you're supposed to be all those things.
So if you are
okay,
then realize that in order to be
successful member of the team,
you need to put all those little
characteristics into check. Yeah,
okay.
Pragmatically and make it happen.
It's funny,
I was reading about that very
recently about I and j t and all that,
the break, Scott introvert,
introvert, extrovert
and
yeah. So there's that framework
and, but as it turns out,
it's like a bell curve where most people
are somewhere in the middle and you
kind of bounce in the middle there.
So there's extreme introverts for sure.
Extreme extroverts, but usually
it's you, you're in the middle,
you know? Yeah. Cool. There's a framework.
Cool. Another thing with that is,
is just like Gary said, the
self fulfilling thing. So, uh,
and I always say this just to my friends,
whatever the different
like feeling a certain way.
I don't think you should have too much
guilt and feeling a certain way. Like,
you know, sometimes there'll be like,
Dang, I've, I felt like, I dunno,
I felt prejudice or something like that.
And just be,
cause those feelings come
from a bunch of things that,
that a lot of time you can't control,
but behavior is different so you can feel
one thing and behave if your behavior
is just based straight up on
your feelings since that's like,
that's kind of whack, you know,
you gotta be smarter where okay,
you have these natural feelings. Cool.
So you're an insurer, I whatever.
And so yeah,
you might tend to have certain types of
feelings or lack of tolerance for this
or you're not tolerant for, you know,
this or that. So when you're like, Hey,
I'm this, therefore it gives me a pass
to behave this way. It's like, Dang,
Bro, you can't do that man.
And if you're intuitive,
but shouldn't you kind of know that?
I guess I would think.
I would hope so. But yeah, so again,
there's a difference between like feelings
and behavior and usually out would be,
you know how you say like, yeah, if you
want to tough, if you want to be tougher,
be tougher. Yeah. A lot
of times I'd be like,
well there's more to it than that in there
is really, but in this case in a way,
bro, you can really look
at it literally like that.
If you have a lack of tolerance
for emotional bro, just
tolerate it, probably you,
you self.
I think people do self diagnosed and,
and give themselves a pass
and I know we kind of have,
I think we do it naturally too because
I know this can put it real ambiguously
cause I don't call anyone out,
but the,
I know this family where the little
girls growing up, they were like,
they kept telling her, hey you're
acting this way because you have a,
I don't know, I forget what I think
aspergers or something. Something. Yeah,
some he goes,
oh that's just your thing.
And they didn't like cultivating anything.
They were just like real dismissive
about it. That's it. And then now,
every time she acted up, she wouldn't
like try to curb her behavior.
She'll act up and be like,
that's just my, whatever,
my Asperger's or whatever that she
liked, embraced it, still behaved,
you know,
in whatever way she felt like behaving
and then just kind of put it on the
aspergers. Yeah, you can.
It's mind control. Yeah man.
It's mind control.
You got,
I mean obviously you get some people
that have some significant, you know,
a mental problem. Okay, I understand.
But like this person that's
writing a logical question,
they got mine control. They
just need to say, you know what?
I'm going to be more open
to other people's emotions.
I'm going to listen to other people's
ideas. Ready to go do it now. Yeah. Oh,
I'm rejecting echos. Echos,
idea at point blank range. Okay.
That's a signal I need to not do that.
I'm open to your ideal. Let me hear it.
It's that easy. That's just my I n t
j acting up and I got to, you know,
I gotta check that. Got a check. Yeah.
The feelings versus behavior thing. Um,
I think is,
well it's one of those things where
when you know the problem that's like,
cause this person's obviously ahead
of the game because they know,
they know this is what's
causing, okay, I can, you know,
I can identify when I feel that
stuff coming on. Very important.
Like it's an ailment, you know,
it's not ailment. It's good still.
All right,
next question.
Next question.
Is this the last one going out with yeah.
I think maybe make this the last one off.
Okay.
Jocko. We all know bad things
happen to good people sometimes.
How do you deal? How do you deal when
those things happen to people around you?
Very true.
That sometimes bad things,
horrible things happen to good people and
I don't,
I don't know why,
but
life isn't fair that that's,
that's the reality and disease like
cancer in Ms and a horrible diseases and
accidents and
these things.
A good person in the wrong place
in the wrong time can
end up just a victim of,
of,
of feet
and end of reality.
And it can be horrible
and a heart wrenching.
But
when those bad things happening
to people around you,
what are you going to do?
How are you going to lead?
Are you going to get angry?
Aren't you going to get frustrated?
Are you going to lash out at people who,
who are you going to lash out at anyways
or are you going to start going down
the spiral of negativity
or are you going to let this horrible
situation dictate the way you feel and the
way you handle it?
Are you going to fall over and fall down,
fall apart
or or are you going to lead,
nor are you going to face this issue
with courage and with resolution?
Okay.
I say lead,
lead,
step up to the challenge.
Be the one that other people look to
absorb.
That impact absorbed that negativity.
Draw fire, draw fire. That's,
that's when a member of a platoon for
for tactical reasons steps into the open
to draw enemy fire.
Maybe to give another part of his team
the chance to move or or distract the
enemy, but that's what I say,
draw, fire, bring that pain to me.
Yeah,
I can handle it when, when,
maybe others cannot.
And when,
when bad things are happening,
I am going to try and
be the one good thing.
The thing standing tall
that can be relied upon.
Okay.
Because I know that that
attitude will spread.
It will bolster those around me.
Okay.
And,
and we will fight.
Okay.
And in fighting we will win.
And if not,
the battle and if not the war,
we will win because our spirit,
it will never surrender.
Yeah.
In that,
that is the ultimate victory to hold your
head high and even even in the face of
inescapable defeat
to stand
and to fight.
That
is to win.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
Okay.
Echo. Yes. Let's close this
thing out a little bit.
Before we do that though,
let's talk about how the people
that are listening to this,
if you want to listen to more of it,
what's the best way to
support the podcast?
What's the best way to get in
the game here with the boys?
Help that help us keep rolling this
thing out. What's the best way to go?
What do we need to clarify or get in
the game means a lot. Yeah. Cause it's,
you're getting in the game and flourishing
in the game really. And to do that,
you may or may not need supplementation.
If you do you like that, like a little,
oh, you went there, what do you call
it? Like a transition anyway. Um,
so supplementation, right? I
need more krill oil by the way.
You should have told me that
before we met today. Yeah. Yeah.
As opposed to right now. Nonetheless
on it, on it has best supplements.
Everyone knows that. I,
I think everyone knows
that by now.
But if you want 10% off and
you're new to on it or are you in,
if you have on it stuff and you'll just,
when you're getting more,
you want 10% off,
go on it.com/jocko 10% off.
If you really want to step
up your supplementation game.
I think I mentioned this once before,
but nonetheless,
it's called stay on it. It's so, you know
how I don't have krill oil right now.
I didn't stay on it. Stay on it is boom,
you hit, it's like the monthly ones. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And
in this case it's like, um,
it's good because it is one of those
things that you need to come back every
month. You need, you need cro. Yeah.
Every month. Every month. Yeah.
And like warrior bars, you need varying
levels of warrior bars per month.
Sometimes more, sometimes lessons.
This is true, but yeah. [inaudible]
dot com slash Jocko 10% off. Boom.
Check out all their stuff. Very good.
Also,
Amazon troop tool does not work anymore.
The Trooper Casey didn't know Troy
by the empire. Yeah. Which, you know,
it had a good run and you
know, cool. But nonetheless,
we are still doing the Amazon thing
and people do support through Amazon,
which is good. Very
good. It's awesome. Yeah.
So what does it cost them to
support the podcast through Amazon?
It costs three seconds of their time.
That's appreciated.
And that's just a one time investment
potentially. If you, you know,
you save it to them, you click
on the k, you go to the website,
check out podcast.com or [inaudible] dot
com click on the Amazon link before he
do shopping,
it'll take you to the m two Amazon.
Save that save the resulting linked in
like a bookmarks is a favorite bookmark
favorite so you can support every time
you shopped and it costs you nothing.
That initial three seconds of your life.
You know,
I lot of people been doing
that and that's, that's
solid right there. Thank you.
Um, but yeah, do it that way.
You can support and also subscribe
on iTunes if you haven't already and
subscribe on Youtube.
I know I've been saying this for year.
You're actually um,
trust level and no man,
you're starting to cost yourself there. I
think it's my fault. Actually Know Matt,
you've been,
you've been giving me trust and brought,
I haven't been throwing it back
at me. I Dunno. Nonetheless,
I know I've been saying it
and where you're getting as
you're going to make more
videos now. Yeah. I'm going to tell you,
just trust me on this.
Everybody that listened to his podcast
wants you to make more videos. No.
Feel any pressure about that. Maybe that's
just not your, maybe you just don't,
you know, you don't want to
make it happen. That's okay.
We want you to know that we all,
all of us,
we all want you to make
more videos. That's the vote
from US troopers over here.
So you got your thing,
you know,
hopefully find some time and
make some bad ass videos.
I'll, um, I'll try. Thanks for
calling them bad ass the welding.
That's my bro. That's
motivating. Thanks. Well,
hopefully you can motivate you enough to
find some discipline to make some more
videos for, for us. Okay, I'll,
I'll do it. Um, but yes, tonight,
youtube, subscribe and
subscribe to the podcast, right?
Yeah. You got to subscribe to the
podcast on iTunes. Yeah. Yeah.
That's the most basic level of,
of joining the movement
is that Tuesday night,
maybe around 11 o'clock, depending on
where you are, depending on where you are.
Maybe it's two o'clock in the morning,
Wednesday night, had a little icon,
comes up with a little one
next to it that you got a new,
a new podcast listen to,
which is, which is good to go.
Yeah. That one is um,
what do you call that?
It's like a Q or something in what they
expect is what's called the variable
reward. Anyway, that's a whole
different thing. Nonetheless.
He was brought up variable reward go.
What is this?
Is this like the endorphins thing where
you see it and you get all excited? Yeah,
it cut out. So variable
reward. It's like when you,
it's like the really,
the iconic cases,
any like Facebook or whatever you see
the one that, the alert, I don't know.
I don't know what it is.
It could be someone talking good about me.
It could be someone invited me to
play a game. It's a variable reward.
Like it could be a fun thing with
a high payoff. Could be low payoff,
but I know it's something, you
know, I don't know what it is. Like,
well they decided they want
to click on it. In this case,
I'm going to go ahead and say I'm,
I know it's going to be a
high value reward when I see
that little one and I go,
yes, I get to listen to the podcasts.
And I know some people said it was weird.
I listened to podcast,
I have to listen to podcasts so
I know what we talked about. B,
what we could do better. Yeah. See
where we need to get better. Yeah.
All those things. So I got to listen to
it. Yeah. Sometimes even when people,
you know, like a lot of times key,
the podcast comes out the next day.
A lot of,
lot of fun.
Twitter are bringing up stuff
that you said or whatever,
and he'd be like, oh wait. Yeah, I
didn't know it came off like that.
Whether it's true or not or whatever. It's
kind of like, so when you listen to it,
you're like way more in tune.
Now this might be a backhanded
compliment or not, I'm not sure.
But when you say something
cool on the podcast,
everybody loves it.
Everyone goes nuts. Yeah.
And I'm not trying to say that you
don't say cool things often cause I,
I think you say a lot of cool things,
but the ones that people
capture and they go, yeah,
Echo said this and they do like,
and they just flood the Inter webs
with Echo Charles, his greatness.
You know what that's like?
It's like one,
a two year old says like a word or like
a one and a half year old says a word.
Oh my gosh.
They said I love you.
Everyone says I love you. It's just the
fact there's not much for your recording.
You said something like pretty
legit before we recorded
today. What did you say?
I don't know. Yeah, you do know
what you said. Say it again.
You get all the people excited anyway.
It might've been something about the Junco
store. It was a gem. I don't remember.
Okay. Always record. Always
record tenacious d fans out there.
You know exactly what I'm talking
about. Alright. Nonetheless,
Jacqueline Stone,
we could talk about that.
That's a good way to get
in the game for sure.
That's where all the shirts and stuff are.
That wasn't really built up.
I'm sitting here and here's the thing
about the shirts. What's on the shirt?
There's a, there's a hidden or not.
So he didn't meaning. So you know,
a lot of times, you know, you
know what the meaning, you know,
if you listened to this and you're kind
of in the game, you know the meaning,
you know, but it's not just a shirt with
the design, there's meaning behind it.
So that's so, so, so,
so if you listen and you know,
right.
And if you don't listen to it, it
makes no sense. It makes less sense.
Put it that way. But yeah, exactly
right. There could be some,
there could be some shirts that make
no sense to anybody. And that's,
did you see,
I put out the old band when I was
a kid and I tweeted this picture,
the tee shirt that we had made.
My buddy had the silk screen still,
so I held it up to the light.
I took a picture,
I posted it.
The name of the band was Bronson's
children as in Charles Bronson,
who when I was a kid,
Charles Bronson,
I thought that he was the man and I
thought it was a man cause you had awesome
movies but that I didn't care about
that. He was a war hero. He was a,
he was in the World War II.
You Purple Heart.
He was a tail gunner just to
just a bad ass guy. And so we,
me and my buddies, we thought Charles
Bronson was the man. So we had our van,
we called it Bronson's children.
So we run that shirt blue. That might
be something people are going to like,
but who's going to look at that and know,
have any idea what
they're going to be like,
hey that kind of looks
like Charles Ronson.
Cause it doesn't even kind of
look like John. It's straight up.
Looks like dropping off. Well
yeah they won't. No, no, no.
The Dia State of Charles Bronson.
I Dunno. His likeness. Yeah,
we'd be definitely using
this likeness. Yeah. Yeah.
But actually Jill Ireland, she, she died
as well. I don't know who's, I dunno.
I Dunno who's left the Bronson family.
I don't know. Maybe we could Debbie.
Good way to get in contact with them,
start producing their
shirts and get sued bio that
Bronson's children would get sued,
you know, cause you're Brunson stilts
variable reward there. Yup. Okay.
I think the shirts are cool. Currently the
bronze and children one that's, that's,
that's a deep one. Two that's good. Um,
but the end, they have layers like I said.
And I'm saying that's a good way to
support. If you don't like shirts,
don't get the shirts. I would say go,
go that, go Jocko store.com. Go there,
look at the shirts. You don't like them,
don't get nothing. Would just look,
could you get a rash card there if you're
so inclined to get a rash guard and
you can get her escort for sure.
The rash guards are good.
I think that's almost like on a
factual level where they're good.
Well there's a lot of people that are,
are,
have experienced the 19% increase in their
jujitsu skills or strength levels and
running. So I had,
so now all my training partners,
or at least a lot of them are wearing
trooper rash guards when they fight me.
So I'm having to fight these guys that
are coming at me and they all look the
same.
They're all monster guys with trooper
tee shirt or a trooper rash guards on it
is not fun.
I'm getting beat up by my own people.
19% more than you were at 90% more
seraph man. It's rough being
Jocko sometimes the um, but yeah,
the rest goes good.
I had a good car,
like kind of email conversation and it's
telling me how wakes up in the morning
does a run, this is in, oh, I'm
totally forgetting where it was,
but just kind of the serenity,
contrast it with the trooper rash guard.
It was, it was nice
nonetheless. You know, uh, the,
the rash guards are good
if you're into it. Jujitsu,
surfing, running and crossfit.
And I know you thought of this and I
know we thought of this, but you know,
I talked Tobar Right now. Yeah, 2016
and we need,
we need hoodies.
And what's the status? Can you
please update me? Two weeks. So by,
by Halloween,
by the end of the month,
people are going to need true blue
hoodies for Halloween. Just Fyi.
I myself included, we are
going to need them. Yeah.
So yeah, hoodies coming out. Um,
we went, I did like an, it wasn't
a poll. What he do, you know,
you can do a poll on Twitter.
I said pull over or zip up.
Pull over one. Yeah, for
sure. I strangely, I like me.
Well that's jacked up.
Actually,
I asked you a long time ago when it was
just like a theory and an idea and you
were like, pull over. I didn't agree,
but I didn't agree. I was like pull over.
You don't know there's a
buck. I'm, but yeah, I,
I think they're both cool for sure. But
um, pullover won by a landslide to, yeah,
it's crazy. No doubt. Um,
nonetheless hope. Yeah, pull
over there you go on the way.
Two weeks, they should be solid.
Um, and then, you know, other stuff,
some girls, tanks, tee shirts
coming out, um, girls tee shirt,
girl's tee shirts.
You're getting abused by the girls.
I will say persuaded.
I see them rough.
You up persuaded they chose not to
flank but persuaded nonetheless.
They're all about the direct
action for sure. Well,
I'm still some women's stuff on there
and more in in some patches. Um,
again,
with the size of the velcro patches,
the two by three is on the way right
now they're four by four across three
inches down. That's big for the
standard Velcro interchangeable.
Right, right. Yeah.
So just know that they're on their
way. Yeah, good. I mean it's, you know,
four with three is fine I guess,
but not free if you're interchangeable
and you got the two by three for all the
military guys and law
enforcement they need,
they need three by two and this is,
I should have told you that and made it
a little more clear. Yeah. But anyways,
nonetheless. Yeah. So the
main thing go there, Jocko.
store.com is just the store with
everything. Again, if you don't like it,
don't get it. But look, you might like
that one and bumper stickers anyway.
Also on Amazon,
you can go and get yourself some
Jocko white day. Yeah. And it's sell.
It sold a lot better. It's
sold, it's selling amazing.
And we got a massive order on the way
and we've also got some restock coming.
So it came originally in these really
nice tins that costs a lot of money to
make.
And so that's cool.
You want to have one of those tens
but if you're doing your reload,
you're going to be able to buy in the
next few weeks you'll be able to buy a
reload a box with a hundred in it,
a hundred so you don't need like another
two and another 10 you can use the same
Tim refill it. So that's
common. And you know what?
If you're uncertain of whether
or not you need the white tea,
it's real easy. Go to Amazon, you
go to Amazon, you read the reviews,
you will be convinced
because they are perfectly,
the Jocko white tea is performing
miracles. Evidently yes,
across the board. So those were awesome.
Go read. Those are funny as hell. So,
and let's see.
Also,
if you haven't gotten extreme ownership
book by myself and my brother Lafe Babin,
just go ahead and grab that
book and own that book.
Take extreme ownership of
the book, extreme ownership
and you'll be good to go.
And,
and also if you have it,
but there's other people that need it.
Sometimes you need to take ownership of
that situation as well and you just need
to buy them a copy.
And also extreme ownership.
The muster in San Diego,
California, October 20th and 21st
it's a leadership conference or are we
talking about combat leadership and the
application of those principles from
combat and how you use them on the
battlefield, how you use them in
business and how you use them in life.
So register, come on out. We'll
see. Then it's getting close.
Obviously Labor's going to be there.
Andrew Paul,
who was on the podcast going to be their
echo. Charles will be in the house.
So come on out and let's,
let's crush that as always,
if you do want to keep it real,
real,
real with echo and with myself,
we kind of rolled deep on the interwebs
and we're there on Twitter for me,
primarily Twitter,
also Instagram,
also that face book,
he is there and we're both on.
Echo is at echocharles
and I am at Jocko Willink.
And last but not least,
thank you
out there.
You listening engaging troops overseas
and that are deploying overseas to hunt
down evil.
Thank you.
Police and law enforcement with an
incredibly hard job risking your lives to
keep us safe.
Thank you
firefighters.
Of course,
that literally run toward fire.
Thank you.
And to the working men and women building,
creating, fixing, buying, selling,
designing,
making this world
thanks to each of you
for what you are doing,
for doing your bit the best you can.
And finally,
thank you all
okay
for getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko.